- Hi, I'm Drew Barrymore,
and I just wanna say to
all the moms out there
that I get it, I know what
being a mom is all about,
and it is the greatest
thing you will ever do.
It's also incredibly hard.
Heart strings pulled, laughs
galore, hair tearing out.
Oh my God, it's everything.
But it is the greatest love
I have or will ever know.
(upbeat music)
- Hi everyone, I'm Chelsea Clinton.
I'm a mom of three.
- Hi everyone, I'm Cynthia Germanotta,
and I have two amazing daughters.
Stefani, who you may know as Lady Gaga,
and Natalie who is a wonderful
and up and coming designer.
- Hi, I'm Ali Wentworth.
I have two adorable teenage daughters.
- Hey guys, I'm Molly Sims,
and to all the mothers out there,
we all know that motherhood
is actually not always glamorous.
- I have vivid memories of the first time
each of my three children
peed all over me.
One, it was while I was
trying to give him a bath,
and it just went boop right up on me.
One, I was trying to change
a diaper, similar trajectory.
And for my daughter, I thought I could
like change her diaper
while she was standing up,
and that didn't work out
really for her or for me.
And yet I wouldn't trade any of them
for anything in the world.
- To all your moms out there,
trust me, I know that
motherhood is not always easy,
but I have to say it's
what I love the most.
It's how I identify the most.
What I do wanna say though,
is as my daughters get older
I still just wanna be a mom.
So maybe I fall into that
category of helicopter mom,
and they're frequently reminding
me, "Mom, we got this."
So I'm learning to back off.
It's one of the hardest
things that I've ever done,
but I have to understand
and respect that they're grown women
and let them go out into the
world and do their thing.
- I remember years ago on Mother's Day,
I was sitting in bed waiting
for cards, candy, flowers.
I got a post-it note that
said, "Love you Mama."
So I had a emergency family meeting,
and I called in my husband,
George and the two daughters,
and I had to educate
them about Mother's Day.
And it might have been
a little passionate,
because I said I live and
breathe and bleed for you,
so I expect a little
bit of love in return.
So all I can tell you is
it's a work in progress.
- I have very young kids.
I have a just turned five year old,
six year old, and nine year old.
And I thought we haven't been skiing.
COVID, haven't really done
a lot, traveled a lot,
let's go skiing.
Let me tell you, the struggle was real.
None of them know how to
ski, which was really fun
when you have three kids,
three different ages
and none know how to ski.
They don't like their boots.
They don't like their gear.
They don't like their mom.
We ended up having a fantastic time.
I literally carried them up the mountain.
The struggle was real.
I love them.
I love them dearly.
But let me tell you something,
I needed a drink, I needed 10 drinks.
Motherhood, it's so fun.
I think that's why I hide in my closet
with my husband sometimes,
and we have like a date
without the kids in my closet.
(tongue clicking) It's true.
- So it may not always be cute or easy-
- But it's always worth it-
- And I'm excited to celebrate
moms this Mother's Day.
- Thanks for having
me, happy Mother's Day.
- Just the happiest, happiest, happiest,
healthiest Mother's Day
to all the hardworking moms everywhere.
- Happy Mother's Day, Drew,
and to all the mothers out there.
- It is truly the best.
And I miss my mom.
- Thank you for having me, Drew.
- Happy Mother's Day.
It takes a village.
It takes a city really.
(upbeat music)